pay my Twitter got hacked dude I saw
that yeah still hacked are you getting
it back what's the I don't know you got
to go you got to get these [ __ ]
emails and things I don't give a [ __ ]
though do you Twitter
yeah I mean I would just prefer not to
have any of my [ __ ] hacked I guess yeah
hey component in the development of the
doozy plus streaming service will no
doubt be partnering with well-known
Brands to produce content I have access
to astonishing data that suggests Home
Depot will be in the market to produce a
sitcom in the next three to five years
will and Chad you must now develop that
sitcom it will be called Welcome Home
Depot this is Welcome Home Depot begin
what is the data I want to see the data
that doozy has that suggests Home Depot
is going to make a sitcom in the next
three to five years it's sort of like
what we were just talking about though
how media is all sort of folding in on
itself hey did you hear about this AI
Darth Vader yeah dude hey did you hear
about the aiufc yep I'm watching it
you're not gonna watch that I'm gonna
watch it
um but I could see something like that
happening too with especially with this
like if Home Depot's got [ __ ] oh we
got extra two million dollars on our
[ __ ] ad budget this year why don't we
just fire that into an AI and have it
[ __ ] out of [ __ ] 10 episode sitcom
well it's not online Welcome Home Depot
Welcome Home Depot okay which is not
just that sounds like a good a good
title doozy but it's also the only title
uh
uh you know what I mean it's like
Welcome Home Depot kind of like hints at
somebody is coming back to this it's
like somebody's dad owns a Home Depot or
something well or it could be like
yeah I guess no they wouldn't be going
home like
no or or what if it's a family that
lives in like the uh like the furniture
part of Home Depot or the Home
Furnishings where you look like you're
in the house yeah no that's not good I I
think it's like some somebody like a
family business is owning this Home
Depot but the sun has said [ __ ] you dad
I don't wanna I don't want your [ __ ]
business and the sun has gone off to
like music school and has lived like a
shitty life but now realizes like I need
to come back home I need to come back
home and do my Home Depot family
business and the guy who owns it is sort
of the big like the uh the what's his
face in in Tommy Boy the Brian Dennehy
yeah the dad to the Tommy Boy character
right and and he's he's got the guy
coming back is that is that person in
the in the Home Depot guy in The Home
Depot thing the person who owns the the
that
franchise location yeah I mean is that
how Home Depot works as a franchise
let's say it isn't ours he owns a
franchise Home Depot so it's like so
it's a little kooky I don't think it is
weird Home Depot yeah I don't think it
is either but I love that idea it's
almost like uh McDaniels in yeah in
Coming to America exactly uh where yeah
that that's and I won I want the sun to
be played by Charlie Sheen
so wait hold and who's the dad
who's the dad that's brought Charlie
Sheen back uh up the it's uh is he also
the manager I think he's the owner of
the manager he's like they're doing
everything he's like very Hands-On he's
poured his life into this [ __ ] Home
Depot can I ask you one question before
I answer who because I think I have a
pitch is it actually Charlie Sheen or do
you want to do like a younger AI Trope
yeah younger AI Charlie Sheen it's like
a 22 year old Charlie Sheen who's like
gone to music school he's been out in La
partying he had a band that fell apart
it hasn't worked out well and now his
dad is maybe like sick but still pushing
himself [ __ ] working himself to the
Bone to keep this Home Depot going okay
so now the and the reason I ask is
because the person I want to play the
father is actually deceased yeah
whatever we aim and it's not bringing
back and it's not the Darth Vader voice
okay it's uh Macho Man Randy
his name is macho manager Randy said or
should he be macho manager or something
that rhymes with Randy Savage module
manager Andy cabbage no that's stupid
this is Tom Macho manager Randy Savage
yeah and then uh and then Charlie Sheen
could be Charlie Sheen yeah Charlie
Sheen's name is Charlie Sheen in the
show yeah okay
um and what's and so it's I can see the
opening scene as like Charlie Sheen you
know knocks on the [ __ ] front door of
the Home Depot
yeah he's after hours but the dad lives
in the Home Depot too yeah that's right
Macho Macho manager Randy Savage is in
the Home Depot Charlie Sheen knocks on
the [ __ ] uh you know the glass
sliding doors and uh Macho manager shows
up and like pajama pants yeah and he's
just like you know he's like eating a
[ __ ] uh you know he's eating a bowl
of ice cream and he's in the [ __ ] uh
section with the shitty TVs watching the
TV sitting on a on a lawn chair and he's
like
who came back yeah Mr rock star Mr
artist yeah hey Dad how you been how's
the Home Depot been going yeah how's the
Home Depot been going
uh
yeah the Home Depot's been pretty good
but one thing I want to ask you right
now yeah is have you called your mom ah
now dad she died two years ago I know
it's been hard for you to let go but
it's just us now so it's you and me
Macho Man and Charlie Sheen and uh Macho
Man is a widow yeah has been widowed by
Charlie Sheen's mom yeah and so he's and
he's hailing now I think he should have
some kind of thing that is like this is
why Charlie Sheen has come back I don't
know about ailing just because I think
that's in poor taste because the Macho
Man is no longer with us all right okay
all right
um uh how about he's uh in legal trouble
I like that that's good uh so the Macho
Man somebody broke their leg in like
aisle 15 in the lumber aisle and is
suing them for everything some kind of
like smarmy 90s lawyer character again
like a Billy Madison type I'm gonna come
in and take everything from your family
right that's kind of like overly
litigious nerd yeah yeah and um how do
we get uh wrestling involved in this uh
you have Macho Man Randy Savage playing
one of the main characters I think
you've done it that's a really good
point
um what if what can we get more
wrestling okay okay how about this how
about this yeah
so Macho Man Okay so the pilot episode
Charlie Sheen comes back to Macho
manager Randy Savage he opens the door
he's having some ice cream and there
they are over a bowl of rocky road you
know it's like okay you know you're
gonna have to live with me but there's
gonna be rules yeah I don't like rules I
like beanie cheese burritos or whatever
and uh it's sort of that formulaic thing
where they've decided to make a go of it
almost like the pilot of Two and a Half
Men it's one of those the premise of the
premise pilot of like here's the whole
thing like Jack Tripper waking up in the
bathroom Three's Company and in order to
so there's a there's a lawsuit happening
because someone fell off a [ __ ] thing
there should be a twist all right here's
Charlie Sheen is like Dad I think you
should sell the Home Depot to the lawyer
I think it's the best move
and he's like what the [ __ ] are you
talking about we find out Charlie Sheen
has been paid by that lawyer to come
back and get Macho Man to sign over the
thing but by the end of the pilot Sheen
twists back and realize that this lawyer
is a piece of [ __ ] this is my dad this
is my family this is my home sweet Home
Depot or whatever this is my Welcome
Home Depot I don't know and I'll tell
you why I and I'm gonna just flying in
the face of your pitch I'm gonna say I
don't necessarily like it because it
makes me uh it makes Charlie Sheen
unlikable to me and I really want to
like the Charlie Sheen character but by
the end he's going to become likable
because he's going to realize the error
in his ways yeah but he does such a
shitty thing right and then he
apologizes for it and and will spend the
rest of his life making it up to Macho
Man okay and that's what the the show is
it's basically Macho Man lording over
Charlie Sheen for the rest of the entire
series I got a pitch for you with regard
to how Charlie Sheen wins his father the
Macho manager Randy Savage back at the
end of the show okay he realizes that he
doesn't want to be with this evil guy
he's like I'm gonna go go in for my old
man I'm gonna I'm gonna help him and I'm
gonna be a part of this Home Depot and
what he does is he stays up all night
and he because the Macho manager is like
I want to take care of this no good
lawyer yeah this is that lawyer's cup of
coffee in the Home Depot yeah he doesn't
belong in our own people no and if I
gotta do it myself I'm gonna make sure
that this smarmy lawyer gets his
comeuppance yeah and here's what happens
Charlie Sheen hears his father he has
this change of heart yeah and he stays
up all night one night and he builds a
wrestling ring in the Home Depot perhaps
the gardens I love this and so that
Macho Man can challenge the smarmy
lawyer right to a match
and whoever wins the match has control
but maybe it's also a fundraising thing
which was big in the 90s where they
throw some big event like the lawyers
like you owe me a hundred thousand
dollars by next Friday or I'm taking
control of the Home Depot right and so
they put on a wrestling event to get
money and the final matches between
Macho and the smarmy lawyer and does the
smarmy lawyer realize that this is
what's going to happen to him uh no I
think it's a thing where it's like we've
got the money and the lawyer's like fine
I'll take the money or put your money
where your mouth is oh Russell you in
the ring wait he challenges macho man
yeah
well that's certain Doom
well we don't know who's playing a
lawyer but yeah I like what if the
lawyers take her
yes the lawyer is played by the
Undertaker yeah no no not the Undertaker
Macho Man would have his hands full with
the Undertaker and also I don't really
think an AI no actually an AI Undertaker
is really good Undertaker AI Undertaker
versus AI macho man but the Undertaker
has to be
um he has to play it straight he's
almost like he's like himself Mark
Callaway right the lawyer's name should
be Mark Callaway attorney at law and
it's Undertaker with a short like red
haircut and why is that because the
Undertaker is naturally has red hair oh
and I think he should have just like you
know like a red he should have red hair
uh like a very nice you know combed red
hair and he always wears a uh like a
ill-fitting gray suit and uh and he's
like
when I uh let Macho manager Randy Savage
when I take control of this Home Depot
it will rest in peace he still talks
like them taker should put a pill in his
waistband and crush it up and throw it
in Macho Man's eyes Bloodsport style at
the in the end of the match and Sheen
has to come in and and he has to help
his dad fight it's like a but one blind
wrestler and his son tag teaming taker
hmm gonna disagree with that because
ticker doesn't really need to cheat to
win it's going to be an uphill battle
for Macho Man to be I like that in this
weird world we're like hey I'm watching
members AI taker in a Home Depot sitcom
put on by dudesi plus starring a young
Charlie Sheen and a AI resurrected macho
man you're like okay all of that yes but
we can never denigrate the idea of taker
he would never have to cheat that's true
and also Roman Reigns is gonna beat
Logan Paul so what else is new what if
he doesn't what do you mean what if he
doesn't they're at this show listen
traditionally these uh the Saudi shows
say what you will about uh
what's going on yeah well that was a
different timer hold on a second years
ago yeah and then Tower seven
that's true yeah it just falls out why
don't you tell me hey we're having a
good time here on doozy doing voices but
I want to say this uh it's those those
Saudi shows you know what I mean they
don't really count they don't really
count they're not part of the storyline
so I couldn't Muhammad Salman wants to
have uh Logan Paul and Roman Reigns
there I mean this [ __ ] wanted
the ultimate warrior in King Kong Bundy
to show up they're both dead how much
money do you think he would have to pay
the WWE to have Logan Paul win that
fight oh
no not 100 million
that's nothing to him yeah maybe about
let's say 25 50 million no no I think
Logan could win that
no Roman Reigns has been the world
champion uh the Undisputed uh Universal
World Heavyweight Champion for over two
years now we're talking about the
bloodline yeah but we're talking about
Sami Zayn I know we're talking about now
we got uh knowledge me yeah we got uh
Solo sakoa in there we got the Usos we
got Jimmy Jimmy
the ones there's no way that Logan Paul
just hear me out they manufacture some
storyline where Logan Paul wins but it's
under some kind of suspicious uh format
it's he does something that could be
construed as cheating so it's not a
legitimate win but he still beats him in
the ring you don't think that could
happen not against the travel Chief no
not unless uh Logan Paul
uh had uh someone on his side perhaps a
manager I pitched myself during that
yeah that pay-per-view although I'm kind
of joking Logan Paul doesn't need a
manager he's got a mouth on him he can
talk and Paul heyman's doing some of his
best work let me tell you this I know
this is straying from our ideal a little
bit but I do want to say where the [ __ ]
is Paul heyman's Emmy that guy should be
winning an Emmy
well he's got the book with that Roman
Reigns statement dude thank you moving
on that's why all his [ __ ] is top-notch
please
here's what you do
please tell the friends
[Music]